the U.S midterm elections have arrived
the turning point for control of
Congress and President Joe Biden's
agenda for the next two years voters say
the country is in serious trouble well
with everything going on around US
inflation and crime you know it's huge
it's huge things are only going to get
worse if you don't make a change our
whole voting system is going to be on
the line here if we don't win the
governorship for instance and if we
don't have at least some majority in
this in the Senate I mean it's uh
it's just critical after Republicans
spent months suggesting Democrats would
try to steal the election the justice
department deployed lawyers to more than
60 cities to ensure there weren't any
problems counting the vote
some Republican candidates continued
their fear-mongering outside the polls
they may be trying to slow a red tsunami
but it's coming and we are going to take
back Arizona meantime Joe Biden
campaigned for Democrats hoping they can
help him boost his economic policies and
his likely re-election campaign today we
Face an inflection point
one of those moments that comes around
every three or four generations
we know in our bones that our democracy
is at risk and we know that this is your
moment to defend it it's likely election
officials will need days to confirm
results in several key states such as
Georgia Pennsylvania Nevada and Ohio
Rosalind Jordan Al Jazeera